The best movie twists are the ones that change
everything that came before it.
Ones that make you want to immediately go
back and rewatch the movie for clues you may
have missed.
Movies like this are the reason spoiler warnings
were invented, so consider yourself warned.
However these twists were so good that they’ve
become common pop culture knowledge and required
viewing for any film fan.
So if you still don’t know who Luke Skywalker’s
father is, we apologize in advance.
Here are 10 shocking plot twists you never
saw coming
Empire Strikes Back
The first Star Wars film set up one of cinema’s
all time greatest villains.
Not only did we see Darth Vader is willing
to decimate entire planets, we also learned
that he was directly responsible for the death
of our hero’s father.
Fans who lined up around the block to see
Luke take on Vader had no idea what was in
store for them.
Can you imagine what would have happened if
Empire Strikes Back had come out in the internet
age?
One of the all-time greatest movie plot twists
probably would have been spoiled for millions
by fanboys who had just had their minds blown.
Considered by many to be the definitive Star
Wars movie, Empire set the bar for franchise
plot twists.
Harry Potter and the Deathly Hollows
You have to give J.K.
Rowling credit for keeping a secret for seven
books and seven movies.
Snape was always one of the most interesting
characters in the Harry Potter universe, but
we had no idea how important his role would
be until the story’s final instalment.
Clearly never a fan of Potter’s, we never
knew if the professor was a full fledged practitioner
of the dark arts, or just kind of a dick.
When he killed Dumbledore at the end of Harry
Potter and the Half Blood Prince, that question
seemed to have a pretty definitive answer.
In Harry Potter and the Deathly Hollows it’s
revealed that this was all part of an elaborate
plan Snape and Dumbledore concocted and Snape
has been helping Harry all along, it changes
everything you thought you knew about the
character.
Acting out of an unrequited love for Harry’s
mother, it’s Snape who sacrifices the most
to rid the world of Voldemort.
Oldboy
Is there a more messed up, harder hitting
twist ending than Oldboy?
I don’t think so.
When Dae-Su Oh finally learns the reason behind
his mysterious 16 year incarceration and the
strange string of events that followed, he
probably wished he’d never gotten out of
that hotel room.
An elaborate revenge plot involving hypnosis
and incest make this one of the most shocking
movie endings of all time.
The Force Awakens
With The Force Awakens now on Blu-ray, Star
Wars fans have had ample opportunity to see
it.
The cat’s out of the bag.
Our favourite smuggler bit the dust at the
hands of his own son.
This development had people talking in hushed
tones when the film was first released for
fear of spoiling it for anyone who hadn’t
seen it yet.
It was the best kept secret in a film with
many secrets and surprises.
With much of the movie based around Solo,
it felt like a proper sendoff while also setting
up Kylo Ren as a heartless villain.
If only Han had known that walking out onto
a bridge like that never ends well in Star
Wars.
The Departed
The ending of The Departed confused many people.
The movie had so many double crosses that
you’re left with a pile of rats with their
tales in one big knot.
Mark Wahlberg’s character seemed to be the
only honest cop, until the film’s last scene
when we see him take out Matt Damon’s character
gangland style.
While Wahlberg is still acting in the interest
of the police, he’s employing the other
side’s tactics to get the job done.
Book of Eli
The Book of Eli did an excellent of foreshadowing
its twist without giving it away.
As we follow Denzel Washington’s Eli through
this post apocalyptic world, nobody else seems
better equipped to handle its threats.
More than capable of defending himself against
cannibals and other enemies, it’s revealed
at the end that he has been navigating these
dangers without the benefit of sight.
If you watch the film with this knowledge
you’ll notice him listening and feeling
his way through scenes as Eli takes a page
out of Daredevil’s book by using his other
heightened senses to survive.
The Usual Suspects
The Usual Suspects is about a mastermind criminal
pulling the wool over a detective’s eyes,
and fooling all of us in the process.
Director Brian Singer crafted such an elaborate
web of lies that even the most of the cast
didn’t know who the real Keyser Soze was
until they saw the film.
Singer pulls a real cinematic magic trick
by having us look one way and believe Gabriel
Byrne’s Keaton had orchestrated the film’s
events before revealing that the real puppet
master was in front of us all along.
You can’t blame Detective Dave Kujan for
not suspecting the crippled Verbal Kint, Kevin
Spacey’s performance was so convincing that
he won an actor for his role.
The Sixth Sense
Sixth Sense is known for having one of the
best twist endings of all time.
It was so good that writer/ director M. Night
Shyamalan has been trying to match it ever
since with very little luck.
Watching the movie now, it seems painfully
obvious that Bruce Willis’s character dies
in the first scene and is a ghost for the
rest of the film, but seeing it for the first
time in 1999 had audiences getting right back
in line to find the clues they missed the
first time around.
Fight Club
The first rule of Fight Club is: you do not
talk about Fight Club’s ending with someone
who hasn’t seen it.
The second rule of Fight Club is: expect the
unexpected.
This explosive, mind-bending action comedy
helped the 90s go out with a bang by pitting
Edward Norton’s narrator against his alter
ego Tyler Durden.
Once you realize the two are one in the same,
it seems so illogical that revisiting the
film would surely disprove this left turn,
yet scrutinizing Fight Club only reveals that
David Fincher knew exactly what he was doing
the entire time.
Shutter Island
The name Shutter Island is an anagram for
“Truth and Lies”, which is quite fitting
for the story that sees Leonardo DiCaprio’s
detective character Teddy Daniels investigating
a patient missing from a hospital for the
criminally insane.
Much like Fight Club, the delusional protagonist
turns out to be his own antagonist, as Daniels
learns that he is in fact the missing the
patient and what we’ve been watching is
an elaborate fantasy the character created
to deal with past trauma.
Thanks for watching our list of 10 shocking
plot twists you never saw coming.
What plot twists blew your mind?
Did we leave any out?
Let us know in the comments below and be sure
to subscribe to our channel for more awesome
videos like this one!